Reporter:
Sixteen-year-old Warren Cave
was taken into custody...
Reporter:
The sixteen-year-old boy will be
tried as an adult.
Aaron Paul:
Warren was sentenced to life in
prison for
murdering his neighbor at
sixteen years old.
Aaron Paul:
And he has now spent nineteen
years of that sentence.
(Music)
When you first meet Warren as
this young, shy, strange little
kid,
and now he's a much more
hardened man.
Lauren Neustadter:
Warren is a very, very
complicated character.
He adopted some beliefs that
were not his own, and he became
Lauren Neustadter:
someone other than the person
that his family knew him to be.
This is the only family you got.
Octavia Spencer:
Poppy Parnell is an
investigative journalist
Octavia Spencer:
who helped to send Warren Cave
to prison.
And it's a very uncomfortable
position for her to be in.
She is believing maybe she's
wrong and maybe Warren was
innocent.
Aaron Paul:
So she is possibly the one and
only person that will try to
Aaron Paul:
make the truth reach the
surface.
You are stepping in something
you have no business being
around.
Nichelle Spellman:
Everybody's lives stopped in one
way or the other
Nichelle Spellman:
the night of that murder.
And their existing as the
walking wounded.
You left us.
Owen, you took everything from
me and Warren.
You stole nineteen years of my
life!
Nineteen years!
Kristen Campo:
Melanie is dying of cancer, and
she feels helpless
that she can't help her son and
she only has so much time
to live.
There is this ticking clock to
get out and spend the last
moments with her.
Melanie is a mother who will
not stop until she sees justice
for her son.
Judge:
There's not enough evidence to
constitute a new trial.
Judge:
-Motion denied.
(Gavel bangs)
My son is innocent.
Owen believes his son's guilty.
Brett Cullen:
And doesn't forgive him.
Aaron Paul:
Warren has such an interesting
relationship with his father,
who testified against him.
Stop talking to that woman.
You leave it, or I can make your
life miserable in here.
Not if I killed you.
Octavia Spencer:
Warren Cave makes you hate him.
He makes you love him.
Octavia Spencer:
And you're constantly
left wondering,
Octavia Spencer:
what side of the fence
is this guy playing?
(Music)
Don't let my mother die
alone.
(Music)